president biden under pressure from
democrats to go big on canceling
student debt they want him to erase up
to 50 thousand dollars of loans per
person for tens of millions of americans
take a look
canceling student loan debt is the
single most effective executive
action that president biden can take to
kick start this economy
america does not suffer from scarcity we
suffer from greed we are not going to
let up
until we accomplish it until fifty
thousand dollars of debt is forgiven
for every student in the country
one big question is what happens to the
people who already
paid their loans back you may remember
this dad who confronted elizabeth warren
over the issue
watch my daughter's getting out of
school i've saved all my money she
doesn't have any student loans
am i going to get my money back so
you're going to pay for people who
didn't save any money and those of us
that did the right thing get screwed
of course we did but i worked a double
shift worked extra like dollars and
works he was 10.
degan you're familiar with a lot of the
financial stuff so let me begin with you
student debt in the country is now 1.6
trillion
what do you see as a solution um i see
the problem and the government and all
these politicians are the ones who
created this mess
in part by well subsidizing the debt
allowing colleges to raise their prices
through the roof
telling students that the more you pay
for an education which is
the biggest lie the better the education
oh go and get a bunch of degrees and
don't have a plan when you graduate from
college
about well how are you going to pay that
debt off just borrow as much as you can
that's the essential problem here they
can try and paper over it and cover it
up
by forgiving some if not most of this
debt
but that and that is the biggest problem
let's promote trade schools i should
have been an electrician
wow we're glad you're not martha
do you think the gop could kind of take
away
this issue if they got behind some kind
of legislation
in congress to solve the issue
well i i think the issue goes back to
exactly what degen was talking about
colleges have become too expensive you
know i'm reminded of a story that i did
years ago
about a threat that was made by the
obama administration and joe biden
uh the vice president at the time was
was a big part of this that if they
didn't handle
sexual harassment cases on campus by
creating a little
a judge panel of professors to
adjudicate these cases that they would
be threatened with losing their federal
funding
so i think that it would behoove them to
find a way to put pressure on these
universities to make
sure that they're not finding students
in untenable situations
where your education is something that
you're able to pay for look at purdue
university
uh run by mitch daniels the former omb
director
very responsible way you know they have
a program where if students can't pay
back their debt and you know a couple of
years out of college then they work out
a program with them because the whole
design is so that your education should
be able to be paid off
by the job that you get when you
graduate this is an arcane ridiculous
system and that man is 100
right he's the taxpayer he is the one
who's going to end up footing the bill
and he will get screwed even though
elizabeth warren told him that he will
not
won okay
so jesse i i i'm sorry greg i wanted to
ask you
greg i i want to float an idea what
about
community college what if you made
community college-free a two-year
community college is that a reasonable
option yeah how do you pay i i i guess
you
wouldn't have to pay those teachers
right because they would work for free
and
the people that maintain the college
they would work for free everybody works
for free
in the world of the left this is the
question that no one asks
how do you do this when you forgive debt
how do you do this
the dems never ask that question does
the debt hop on the back of a unicorn
and fly away
no somebody somebody has to foot the
bill
now is it going to be the banks i don't
think they're going to foot the bill
is it going to be the colleges i'd love
to see that you know who's going to foot
the bill
you are and you're going to be ticked
off because you
paid your loan already and you secretly
know
that the person that's getting their
debt forgiven is just
as well off as you are because you know
a lot of them are going to be
white middle-class liberals who have
wealthy parents who could easily pay it
off why not if you're not if you
want to pay off somebody's debt here is
my suggestion if
the average college loan payment is 393
bucks
the average monthly payment for a used
car is
381 why not cancel the debt of all the
used cars
because that used car will get will
the owner will use that far more
than many of these people are using
their college degrees a pickup truck in
idaho
is way more valuable than a fine arts
degree in brooklyn
and it's way more democratic to forgive
auto loans for people using their cars
than for the idiots that chose degrees
that do nothing for them
people should not be paying for other
people's mistakes
so jesse picking up on that idea from
greg
would you say it's okay then to forgive
loans for low-income students
maybe one
i'm paying for your mistakes every
single day so i mean
forgive that love my goodness i mean
greg's right and dagon's right and so is
martha the democrats
created this problem and then are
swooping in with my money to solve it
and then they want an atta boy and then
they want to get reelected for it
they're the ones with the banks and the
loan sharks that created the bubble
and they raised tuition they raised fees
and they got to indoctrinate more
students
in their liberal universities then all
of a sudden it blew up
because people have thousands and
thousands of dollars of debt
they can't buy a house they're living
with their parents and they have a
sociology degree they can't get them in
the door anyway
so why should i have to pay for my
neighbor's dumb daughter
who went to i don't know grad school for
anthropology
who just backed her car into my car and
didn't leave a note
uh-uh i'm not paying for that i mean
we're probably going to bail him out we
bail out other countries detroit
wall street why not bail out these
people the only thing juan that's going
to stop this
it's a collision course between the
socialists and the wall street democrats
who has the power in joe biden's walsh
in joe biden's white house
is it yellen and the wall street
democrats or is it the crazy socialists
like bernie
aoc and chuck schumer we're going to
find out